es ist die geschichte eines reichen
mädchens das so einer ikone der
kunstwelt wurde
auftritt peggy guggenheim die kaiserin
unter den kunst besessen reich visionär
und extravagant das geht nicht mit
meinen haaren
die amerikanerin mit schweizer wurzeln
liebte es die grenzen des guten
geschmacks zu testen mit ausgefallenen
brillen oder abstrakter kunst
meine idee war es eine historische
sammlung aufzubauen mit allen so
realistischen richtungen des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts ihre exquisite sammlung
umfasst über 320 bilder von mehr als 100
künstler darunter die ganz großen wie
miró pablo picasso
oder jackson pollock
treffen mit meyer hoffmann am galerien
wochenende in zürich
die roche erbin und potente
kulturförderung hat mit ihrem ehemann
einen neuen dokumentarfilm über peggy
guggenheim produziert
welche kräfte
sie hatte einen schlechten geschmacks
brille zum beispiel war wahrscheinlich
nicht richtig gute geschmack oder was
denkst du ja ich denke sie hatte einen
schlechten geschmack auch weil sie so
viele tragödien erfahren hat
ja der schlechten nachgeschmack im ernst
sie hatte natürlich einen großartigen
geschmack peggy guggenheim credo lautete
gut ist was mir gefällt
red test
bloß koketterie
und so kaufte sie schon die surrealisten
bevor diese millionen gekostet haben als
mit zähnen war sie eine meisterin ihres
fachs sie glaubte aber nicht an den
profit sondern an die kraft der kunst
das tut auch ulla dreyfus best die
kunstliebhaberin aus basel sagt sie
fühle sich mit peggy guggenheim
seelenverwandt
sie hätten den gleichen geschmack und
einen ähnlichen charakter
deshalb ist hier ein gemälde besonders
wichtig das ist ein max ernst von 1940
mit dem schönen titel swamp angel das
gehörte peggy und peggy hat es in ihrer
ersten ausstellung 1942 in new york in
ihrer ersten auftritt auch gezeigt
dieser sumpf engel hat eine ganz
besondere geschichte oder dreyfus best
verliebte sich in das bild ohne zu
wissen wer die prominente vorbesitzerin
war
peggy guggenheim sammelte
leidenschaftlich und mit courage
die vermögen der erbin war eine zentrale
figur der kunstszene in london und paris
auch während des zweiten weltkriegs
unterstützte sie die kunstschaffenden
unaufhörlich während des krieges habe
ich mir selbst verordnet dass ich
versuche jeden tag ein bild zu kaufen
künstler rief mich den ganzen tag lang
an und kamen morgens in mein haus und
ich kaufte bilder vom bett aus sie
hätten ja selbst ins konzentrationslager
kommen können
hatten sie nie angst vor den deutschen
nein das ist nicht meine art angst zu
haben
1942 eröffnete sie die surreal ist
gallery in new york machte ihre sammlung
der öffentlichkeit zugänglich als eine
der ersten mischte sie in ihren
ausstellungsräumen europäische und
amerikanische kunst damals eine
revolution
mehr eine produzentin als nur eine
sammlerin das heißt sie hat sich auch um
die kinder gekümmert sie hat ein sehr
gutes auge gehabt habe hat mit denen
ausstellungen organisiert ich habe
jackson pollock entdeckt und gefördert
die ersten schritte sind immer die
wichtigsten sie war mit zähnen und
mätresse zugleich unterhielt zahlreiche
liebschaft mit ihren künstlern die
längste beziehung aber pflegte sie mit
ihrer stadt an der lagune
ich gehöre zu venedig venedig ist meine
große leidenschaft
meine große liebe
der palazzo dient heute als museum
und wo ist die exzentrische sammlerin
mit dem angeblich schlechten geschmack
ganz nahe bei rege liebten kunst
sie liegt im garten der villa begraben
zusammen mit ihren 14 hunden